americans are hitting the road with
renewed urgency this fourth of july
weekend
more than 43 million people are taking
some kind of road trip despite sky-high
gasoline prices as coveted restrictions
are lifted
three and a half million others are
expected to catch a flight
elise preston is at laguardia airport
here in new york with more on this story
elise good morning
good morning dana airport officials tell
us passengers should arrive to the
airports early
as there is an abundance of travelers
but a shortage of workers
and that's expected to be evident at
airports today
people just want to go andrew gross
speaks for
aaa and points to packed roads and
crowded airports that are expected to
tally up to 47.7
million travelers this holiday weekend
when you think that
we're still in the pandemic people are
still getting vaccinated
are you surprised that the number is
even that high
not really because we saw how many
people traveled over memorial day
and it was around 34 to 37 million
people traveled
and since memorial day gas prices have
risen the average price of a regular
gallon is three dollars
13 cents a seven year high travel demand
is also pushing prices up for hotel
rooms
and rental cars at atlanta's hartsfield
airport
exasperation was on the rise too
i've been in several different airports
over the last week or so
and atlanta is nets the one and a half
million expected atlanta travelers may
want to bring their own parking spaces
29 000 spots at 11 lots may not be
enough
we do want to remind people that even
with 29
000 spots it tends to get filled up so
check out our website
atl.com we provide immediate updates on
parking availability
where are they all going well top
destinations include las vegas
denver and theme park cities of anaheim
and orlando
by all indicators people are free this
independence weekend uh people are
feeling a lot more
confident about travel uh and i think i
think they kind of get it now you know
they get if they are they be safe if
they're if they have their masks have
their hand sanitizers
obey the rules then it really makes
everything so much easier mass mandates
and airports are still required by
federal law
and the tsa has indicated it is prepared
we brought extra folks on overtime to
staff the checkpoints
now for those who have not hit the roads
yet aaa says this morning
is your best bet but experts stress to
be
patient and remember that traffic jams
are returned
to normalcy jeff a good return to normal
i think
thank you very much i guess